Monsieur le Commissaire madame la
Présidente chers collègues une année
pour la jeunesse était une nécessité se
pose aujourd'hui la question de la
continuité de notre action pour nos
jeunes cette année a souligné combien
nos jeunes ont de la ressource et des
idées
enseignant hier je le voyais tous les
jours député aujourd'hui je souhaiterais
davantage encourager leur esprit
d'initiative et leur créativité
intensifier nos réponses pour améliorer
l'insertion l'éducation pour tous la
lutte contre la précarité ou encore
répondre aux problèmes de santé mentale
constitue notre priorité nous devons
partout mieux former nos jeunes et
continuer à faire de l'Europe un espace
de connaissance les garanties
européennes pour l'enfance et la
jeunesse doivent être plus visibles et
assorties
nous devons favoriser la mobilité pour
nos jeunes en particulier ceux de nos
régions
ultra périphériques afin qu'il explore
le monde d'autres territoires d'autres
cultures et d'autres langues
Erasmus plus est le dispositif le plus
pertinent faire vivre la citoyenneté
afin qu'en 2024 nos jeunes votent
massivement aux élections européennes et
s'implique de manière pérenne dans la
démocratie européenne c'est ma feuille
de route pour l'héritage de cette année
de la jeunesse afin que chaque jeune
sans distinction est la place qu'il
méritent dans notre société